welcome the best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can watch just
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go along
with this video check out the link in
the description below alright so today
is bonus day number five and we're gonna
learn how to improve our relationships
[Music]
we've been together a long time that I
feel like we need to spice things up any
suggestions on how to keep the
excitement alive in a long-term
relationship speak into the microphone
get the mic so we can hear you know what
I would say both ears I would say you do
costumes no I don't do customs you know
once I schoolgirl one side oh my god
once I try a nurse and he plays that
doctor no no once I tried once I tried
this this is so many years ago and I got
the hold negligee thing and I'm standing
at the stairs when he comes in and he
literally comes in Steadman walks right
past me and says what are you doing like
I got one better wrap myself up with
saran wrap no you did yes I did with
when I was married put on the trench
coat he came home with that uh he went
what is that so what starts cuz I hear
the young people today one of spiced
things up so I would say ask him what
would be spicy because you can be
standing there in a saran wrap and saran
wrap or you could be you know wrapping
yourself up as a pretzel you know doing
calisthenics
you can't get limber yeah you could get
limber and he's like what is that so
you'd say what would be the sexiest
thing that I could do or what really
turns you on for me I gotta say making
cornbread China serves the purpose
I made some cornbread yesterday and you
would have thought I stripped myself
naked like a little cornbread in black
eyed peas goes a long way in my house
there you go sleeping together on the
first date yes or no no no / we old Joe
because I well we are old but why buy
the cow when he can get the milk for
free
not that we're cows I'm not saying that
but I just think it changes a dynamic
but guy knows he'll sleep with him on
the first date now if you ask guys they
say that they don't judge you if you
sleep on the first date I think they do
we sound very old that's ok that's ok
we're not old
we're just experienced yeah if you don't
have a goal yeah you know if you don't
have a purpose for your relationship and
pretty much anything is right if you
don't have a purpose if you don't have a
place that you're going something that
you want to accomplish something you
want to do that you can really get lost
in the murk of the the journey it has to
be a vision for it has to be a vision
right so why why are we together you
know it slimy you find you find you you
know but but as an answer for why two
spirits would join together and decide
to travel this a perilous journey of
life together fine or you can cook or
you keep the house protected that's
really not enough there's so much more
that you have to be dedicated to Wow you
know - that is so true of us so what is
the bigger vision for your marriage what
is the bigger well we had to figure that
out because we're too big
beings that came together yeah and I had
my vision and he had his and so we had
to join in so we decided to just do what
she says
we decided once we started to see how
the children were growing and you know
willow and Jaden and Trey with how they
were becoming their own beings we
decided okay we want to make a family
business how do we incorporate all the
talent that we have in this family right
so that's and that's our vision to
create a place where their dreams can
come true and our extended families
dreams can come true as well what I
found in my life for years I had a
relationship with someone was a great
lady and we had tons of love but very
little passion and I wanted more passion
but I didn't understand what the
triggers were I didn't understand the
differences in values and rules I didn't
know how to shift anything nobody teach
you this and so I'd be in this
experience where it's like wow you know
I remember being on stage vividly in a
room that would have been my my ultimate
years before it was at the qanun Hill
Center in New York City there were
13,000 people in the room 12,000
something hundred almost 13,000 people
and I was doing my gig and we were
rocking like what we're doing here was
five thousand thousand thirteen thousand
and we were going full-tilt
with a level of intensity was
unbelievable people are out of their
mind and during one of the stretch
breaks one of my partners came up and
told me my company has gone public that
morning and that's the morning where my
stock Alone's worth four hundred million
dollars so you just made four hundred
million dollars this morning while
you're doing what you love I was like
good morning great morning you know was
interesting it was really great it was
like wow that's wonderful and then what
I really want to do is get right back
into what I loved it didn't like it was
a cool thing but it wasn't didn't change
my life but the biggest thing is the end
of the night night I'm connecting people
high-five and sign and hugging people
and it's just a beautiful day and I get
home and I had made for two million
dollars I've been with almost 13,000
people I've done what I loved I was on
fire and alive and I went home and I was
miserable because when he went home the
person I was with wanted to be be
something different than what I was kind
of like that's why I understood Sarah
may Sarah may was trying to be something
she thinks people want or people are
expecting
from her but it's not her so the person
I was a relationship with when she met
me he's unbelievably this powerful force
of nature he can shake a building with
people move people and then it was like
why are you so loud
I was like wow this is me and so what I
learned to do was be something different
that I really wasn't
and so when you're being something
you're not you're miserable who knows
what I'm talking about here say I and
I'm such a lover I love people I never
want somebody not be happy so I would
always sacrifice everything try to make
somebody happy but by not being who I
was there was nothing wrong with her I
was just miserable cuz I didn't
understand the game when I finally
figured this process out and by the way
guess how I did it I interviewed people
I had a couple that was guy was 92
woman's 89 kina my date with sa seminar
and these two were physically all over
each other all the time I mean so much
so it was like get a room I mean this is
hard to watch
and everybody whole seminar notice it so
I finally bottomed on stage and
interview them
[Applause]
I ship their young bugs in their 60s so
I bring this money through your old man
there's 89 year old woman up and I said
I gotta interview guys so I'm
interviewing him I said to him I said
tell me something I said you two seem to
not just love each other you like love
each other
and they were oh yeah I mean like you're
rather physical aren't you they said oh
yes we love everything we love to be
together I said and you guys have
intimate relations oh yes every day
every day sometimes several times a day
the woman says no exaggeration and they
were so adorable and they were like all
of each other how to get to grab each
other touch each other and I said to him
I said okay there are a lot of people
that think when you're together 3 4 or 5
10 years you know there's nothing new
they said nothing new they just aren't
being in flexible enough they're not
trying new things I said well tell me
something what's your belief about like
how do you stay intimate [ __ ] the woman
says well you can't just talk
you got a Dutch and she said like touch
lots of things and she's so adorable
and so I said so you guys have this
fashionable time Jana so what's your
belief and he said well we believe that
it's never boring because we believe
there's nothing ugly between two people
who love each other nothing dirty
between two people love each other
she said yeah here's our rule we try
anything once and if we like it we do it
again so I spent five years interviewing
people who've been together 20 30 40 50
years and they don't just have love
their passion they're not hanging out
they love each other
and it changed the game for me and the
biggest change in my life I would give
up everything in my life without a no
exaggeration no hyperbole everything
I've ever learned if they ever have done
for the relationship I have with my sage
she has been the great I died for this
woman no exaggeration but I couldn't
have gotten to that place if I hadn't
been through all those other places
first and the gift that I've got in that
area is a gift you deserve and anybody
can have it you could be with somebody
together for 10 years and you could
night it cuz you just to know the
triggers or some of you may find that
you're in a relationship where
truthfully you are nothing in common
you're just scared shitless to end it
because you're afraid of being alone but
there's a way to do this in a way where
things can be elegant but you can be
free and you can bring to your life what
you deserve
I tell people one thing if you're not
happy in your intimate relationship
you're not happy because I don't give a
[ __ ] how hard you work I don't care how
much money you make any troubles you get
in the end if you don't have that
aliveness and passion a part of you is
dead inside my husband has a line that I
always quote because it's it's not all
why I married him but it's a lot of why
I married it was this line he said a
woman's place is in the kitchen with her
feet up drinking a glass of wine
watching her husband cook her a meal
[Laughter]
we're beating up watching your husband
cook her a meal and that is I just
that's it I come home and he loves to
cook and I sit down and this is why I
like it almost was gonna cry but he'll
just stand there and he'll be like I'm
gonna make a big curry I'm gonna make
cuz he loves to do these big Mama's
cooking thing is he's Brazilian but his
mother was Italian so he loves like slow
cooking and then got to invite me to you
or another glass of wine
oh you you are welcome and he'll pour me
a glass of wine and he'll say now
darling tell me everything
Wow what happened today tell me and and
I'll just said there was my feet I'm
like how did I win this life Wow how did
I win this life and and I was talking
about this with a friend and she said
because you blossomed into the sort of
person who attracted a man like that and
you learned how to treat yourself so
well on your own that when someone came
along who treated you well you've
finally recognized what
feels like because you've been doing it
to yourself the whole time hallelujah so
I noticed him I was like oh he treats me
the way I treat me now so yeah let's go
here's the thing about running away from
your problems running away from your
past have you ever noticed that when you
run away it tends to follow you you know
I used to have this problem in
relationships and the reason why I had
this problem is because I was a very
unhappy person I didn't like myself
truly as a person until probably four or
five years ago I spent as sad as this is
I spent the first 46 years of my life
really not liking myself really feeling
like I wasn't a good person really
questioning the sanity of people that
were in love with me or that were
friends of mine because I had such a low
opinion of myself and it didn't matter
you know I I was guilty not of moving
from one city to another but I was
guilty of moving from one person to
another that I would literally get in a
relationship I would be in a
relationship for a year and then I would
start to feel that unsettled feeling
because what happens after a year of
being in a relationship well you got to
start working on it it's no longer the
thrill and the delight and it's new and
you're dating now it's just you and the
person in your life there's nothing new
about it and so all your old crap starts
to show up and that's when you got to
start to do the work and so it was about
the year or the year and a half mark in
almost every single relationship that I
would start getting that itchy feeling
and the reason why I was getting that
itchy feeling is because my past was now
there this new relationship was no
longer new and so I was no longer
distracted by it and I was going to have
to deal with myself in order to be happy
and so what did I do four years not even
just years decades everybody I'm not I'm
not proud to admit this but I would
literally jump out of one relationship
and into another new one because another
new one would distract me from the fact
that I was on half
person true story and I think a lot of
you who are unhappy with yourselves are
looking to move jobs or looking to move
the city that you live in or you're
looking to change your relationship and
the problem isn't where you live the
problem isn't your job the problem isn't
the person that you're with the problem
is how you feel about yourself I think
relationship advice is really difficult
because it just depends where you're at
in your relationship whether you're
happy with it whether you're unhappy
with it whether you've been with
somebody for a long time or not but I
think there are some probably you know
universal things that you can keep in
mind to create greater love great
greater connection create greater I just
frankly joy and acceptance and vibrancy
and and sensuality in your relationship
and the first one is to practice
positive projection what that means is
is you should be assuming the best about
your partner and projecting positive
traits and ideas onto them assume that
they are doing their best assume that
they are thinking of you assume that
they are trying to do things for you
assume at that at least they're not
trying to cause any harm and this is a
tough one especially if you've been in a
relationship a long time because you've
probably already discounted me and this
video just because of that piece of
advice right you say no no no Brendon
you don't understand my person is always
a bastard my person is always trying to
do this to me they're always trying to
do that to me and may a look I don't
know your situation that could be true
but what we do know from relationship
science and it is a science and you can
study communication you can study the
different ways that people connect and
their intimacy and their relationships
in their marriages and you see over and
over and over again that often one
partner says something to their other
partner and that person completely blows
up in their mind with this big story
about how this other person is you know
trying to control them how this other
person is clearly belittling them is
clearly being condescending is clearly
hurting them but when you look at the
transcripts of their conversation you
see that the partner over here
really just said something very
matter-of-factly and this person who's
offended drew all of their past history
or some negative parts of the couple's
history into that conversation and
projected that on to what the person
said in fact often in conflicts the
person who's the most angry can't
remember what the other person even said
they can't recall the exact words they
just said well they made me feel this
way and the reality is that person
didn't say anything that would from a
third party standpoint cue those
emotions would cue that frustration or
that anger but what we all do is we just
take what's upset us in the past we take
our old patterns our old beliefs our old
hurts and our old pains and we bring
them into our relationship with somebody
and especially in a conflict now we
think that somebody's trying to hurt us
we think that somebody's belittling us
when the facts of what they said aren't
that big of a deal in other words we
blow things out of proportion because of
our past not necessarily what is being
said or displayed right in front of us
so as a rule the best thing I feel that
we can do in our relationships is to
practice positive projection just assume
that the other person is there with you
for you and in love with you
I think that you know what they just
said they're not trying to offend you
they would just might be in a bad place
you know they might be frustrated they
might be tired they might be distracted
and don't get mad at them realize hey
you know what
this person is doing the best they can I
mean imagine if we just project a little
if we gave them more patience to those
that we loved and we projected an
assumption that they were doing their
best and that they were in love and that
they were with us and that they were
trying I think that if you're in a
relationship that matters a relationship
that's important to you a relationship
you want to stick with you've got to
start assuming better about your partner
you got to give him credit and the Ben
the doubt again because you've probably
been projecting all your negative stuff
your own fears your own inadequacies
your old upsets your bad beliefs into
the conversations and it's tearing you
apart so you gotta figure that one out
practice positive projection I think the
second thing we have to do is to learn
to listen longer and I know you're
probably like oh yeah yeah yeah Brendon
listen I guy know I gotta listen no I
know but people always say you know be a
better listener I say well the essence
of being a better listener
is to listen longer see respect is
really just a demonstration of listening
a little longer and I think what we have
to do is train ourselves to be more
patient with people to listen to them
without trying to solve their issue
without trying to input our own story
without trying to figure out the root
cause of what's going on for them I know
this as a man right when I listen to
somebody especially a female and she's
she's upset about something or she's
venting about something or she's
complaining about something or she just
speaking about something that she's very
frustrated with and it comes at me it's
easy I get up I'm like I just want to
solve it I want to stop the noise no but
that is not a way for me to deepen my
relationships what we have to do is
allow people to vent at us a little
longer without losing our patience
matter of fact some of my best friends
in the world I tell them the 20 minute
listening challenge when they get home
when their spouse comes up to them and
start sharing about the day and wants to
talk about a bunch of things I tell them
just weather that storm for 20 minutes
just listen for 20 minutes try not to
solve anything try to reflect back what
they're saying or just even be quiet and
let them just go and you know what the
funniest thing is after about 20 minutes
almost everybody runs out of gas now you
say no no no no I'm ready my partner can
talk for hours and hours and hours that
might be true but usually when they
first connect with you then they first
see you when they haven't seen they just
there's a twenty minutes of something on
and at the end of women's they kind of
run out a little
oh yeah so so how are you and that's we
say oh you know it is a really crazy day
hey would you mind if I just go get
settled just give him the twenty minutes
just if you and you pull up to your
house if you have to you know just sit
in the car center yourself then go
inside the house and let them get you
for twenty minutes just give them twenty
minutes give them Tony you could give
them twenty minutes
you love them give them twenty minutes
then get yourself settled but if I think
we can learn to allow people more time
to talk we start to find greater
connections with people often we just
cut them off
often we interrupt them we tell them
what to do and the worst thing we often
do is we say hey you shouldn't feel that
way and here's why all right hey why are
you feeling that way and we try to do
some root cause analysis when really we
could just allow them to express
themselves and they'll find their own
way
so listen longer I think the third doing
we have to do to maintain a great
relationship is we got to escape
together you got to get out I mean every
week you should go on a date night or
every other week and you should every
three months disappear you know I tell
people if you've read the charge or a
lot of my work we say you know the 90
day challenge which is every 90 days you
and your spouse your partner lover
getaway go somewhere you know give the
kids to somebody you know give the kids
the grandparents to the neighbors to the
babysitter or whatever you do go away
for two or three days those two or three
days are vital they could be you know
anywhere they give you gets do them at
home you could go to a hotel you could
go on vacation together but every 90
days you've got to schedule it and
disappear together where the two of you
are not working are not well are not
with the kids are not in a place where
are you or have the demands of your
career or your work where you can just
turn off and people say all the time
well Brendon sure you can do that but
not everybody can do that I'm like no
everybody can do that if you can't in in
if you think about it in three months of
time if you can't take two to three days
off with the person you love then what
kind of life have you set up for
yourself
that's the question we have a great
amount of control over our lives a
tremendous amount of choice as trainers
amount of decision and we get to choose
what are we doing with our time and if
you set up your time so irresponsibly
they you can't take two to three days
off every 90 days then it's time to
reclaim your orders life agenda let me
read my book the motivation manifesto go
out there study some things on
productivity study some things on how to
get your time back make better choices
for yourself but at least decide your
life I mean you deserve at least I mean
if every three months you can't take a
couple days off what's going on with you
it's time to look at yourself and it's
time to look at your relationship if
your relationship isn't important enough
to give it a couple days
you know once a quarter then maybe
you're in the wrong relationship or
maybe you're approaching the idea of
relationships wrong or maybe you've
never prioritized your relationship and
that's why it hurts so bad I say the
last piece is that I think it's really
important to stay in your job in a
relationship and I don't mean by your
employment you can quit your job but
don't quit the relationship but what's
your job in a relationship it's to love
and it's so easy to forget that because
we get mad at somebody and they didn't
run the task or into the garbage or take
out the dishes wait I think I got it
backwards but they forgot something and
we get mad at them when we forget our
job there is to love and if you're
really going to choose love over
choosing your past or you're going to
choose love over fear or hurt or pain or
choose love or being you know right then
you're gonna start to find something
switches in that relationship and it's a
good thing see most people aren't
choosing love they're choosing fear most
people aren't choosing love their
choosing hurt and because of that over
and over and over again that simple
choice in the relationship they're not
approaching the relationship with the
intention of love right if you can
approach your relationship with the
intention of love to say look I'm just
gonna keep bringing joy and love and
acceptance and compassion
and empathy and vibrancy and sensuality
to this relationship and you're always
doing that more often than you're
bringing the negative stuff that
relationship will suddenly start to turn
positive it will get easier as you
change your intentions to be more geared
towards love that's your job stay in
your job in the relationship to love
this person to make their day to
surprise them to care for them stop
asking so much what you're getting from
the relationship and how they've done
you all wrong and start asking what have
you been doing right what have you been
doing to add value love energy vibrancy
sensuality to their life what have you
been doing to love them ask the question
how can you deliver more love to your
partner and to the world and you might
start to experience what we call the
charged life the other day one of my
friends asked me just what is a healthy
relationship you don't have to scratch
my head for a minute because I realized
that there are many many people who have
no clue what it is what it means what it
takes to have a healthy relationship a
healthy relationship is one you want to
be in not one that you are in or have
been in so long you don't know how to
leave or one that you used to being in
or one that you're in out of habit or
obligation or a sense of responsibility
a healthy relationship is one that you
want to be in because it is good for you
and the other people involved which
brings us to the second element a
healthy relationship is one in which you
feel affirmed supported and encouraged
to be the best person you can be in fact
a healthy relationship makes you want to
be a better person this means that you
can be your authentic self your real
self at all times with the person you're
in relationship with you have your
strengths that are recognized
your weaknesses and shortcomings that
are accepted not criticized but that
you're also supported in working out and
working through you have your individual
talents and interests that are supported
and your voice your view your needs are
considered and the things that you do
together in a healthy relationship you
get to be you as you change and shift
and grow without being expected to be
who the other person or people need and
want you to be in order to keep them
comfortable I think another sign of a
healthy relationship is that there's
trust honesty respect compassion
forgiveness compromise and a shared
vision shared interests and a
willingness to practice all of those
principles and live up to them to the
best of your ability
I hope the relationship is also the one
that you're prepared to work for and
work on yes a healthy relationship
requires a lot of work however when you
want to be in the relationship when
you're passionate about the relationship
and it's health it won't seem like work
at all a relationship is a living thing
it needs to be nurtured and nourished
and if you want to keep the relationship
healthy you can't just sit back and wait
for the good times to roll in
you need to initiate it this means you
have to look for ways to create happy
memories all of the time even if it
means doing something silly that you
both enjoy now that we have some of the
elements because this list is in no way
complete let's look at some of the ways
that activate what's required for a
healthy relationship let's start here
communicate communicate communicate
talk about who you are because you're
changing day by day moment by moment
talk about how you are changing
talk about what you want and what you
need talk about your strengths your
weaknesses your fears talk about what
you see and what you know and always
always be as honest as you can and as
much as you talk listen listen with your
ears listen with your heart this is what
your soul and always be willing to hear
something new about the other person and
never ever ever use what you hear as a
weapon or tool for dishonorable
intentions stay present in your
relationship if you want your
relationship to be healthy and stay
healthy then you have to be in it
mentally emotionally physically and
spiritually be mindful not to allow
outside responsibilities demands and
interests to take your mind and heart
and your soul out of the heart of the
relationship if your time and energy and
attention is being drawn away
communicate that communicate what you're
up to
so that the other person knows and is
aware even if they don't like it or
don't understand at least they will know
that you're still present just want to
ask about personal relationships as far
as you know you're going after it your
goal is in life my body is one of the
easiest things I'll tear the parts that
do whatever I have to do but it's the
mental the mental thing you know you
kind of get attached to me it's a
romantic relationship and I have certain
goals I want to attain but instinctually
I know this is going to hold me back you
know
well I hate to tell you this but I tell
you this city would you ask me question
oh it's hard it asks this question that
if I play truth you're if you're you're
never going to be happy a hundred
percent of anybody natural quit until
you are happy with yourself 100 percent
its gotcha so if you said oh honey I
love
listen there that's you got to do it's
gonna be right back here every day you
wake up oh and then one day you can just
girl by math gave up this you're gonna
hold a grudge you might have what see
Michael dude do you finish you make sure
you feel good and then you are totally
open to a relationship but until like
launch it by the mere fact that man did
I do the right thing so I'm all about
man you got a people Hutchins force in
with yourself before he could be one of
those I could see with anybody else now
I've got a special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best life 30 questions
of the day it's not enough to just watch
a video like this you have to do
something and take action in your life
so pull out your worksheets and answer
these questions and if you don't have
the worksheets yet you can get them for
free by signing up for the series in the
description below here we go question
number 1 how can you bring more passion
to your relationship
number 2 what do you need to stop
running away from and number 3 how will
you spice things up with your partner
and if you're doing the best life 30
challenge with me give me a hashtag best
life 30 down the comments as well so I
can celebrate you I think if you have a
partner who doesn't support your
business you're either gonna lose your
business you're going to lose your
partner it's really hard to be mission
driven and want to have a successful
company and being a relationship with
somebody who doesn't support you I think
there's four buckets that people fall
into two of them are negative and two of
them are positive the two and the
negative side you have a partner who
just absolutely hates what you're doing
you have a partner who just doesn't
believe in what you're doing they hate
it they think you should quit they think
it's tearing down the family they just
don't want you to do anything with
related to that business and that really
sucks as a place to be you can't
continue on with your business and your
relationship you have to figure out a
way to make it happen the second bucket
is they tolerate it they're not happy
with it but they tolerate it and that
also really tough place to be because
anytime you are struggling any time
you're not getting results anytime
you're coming home when you're stressed
out they're gonna say see see I told you
that business you shouldn't be doing it
they barely tolerate it but they're not
on your side they just do it because
they want you to have your thing and
they love you but they're not really on
your side they don't want it to succeed
it's a really hard spot to be in if
that's you and an entrepreneur and that
being your partner it sucks
now we move into the positive side the
next step up as they support you they
support you they believe in what you're
doing they may not be involved in it but
they want you to be happy they believe
in your mission they're their pump that
you're up doing your own thing and they
support you and you going off and
accomplishing your goal and then the
last one which is ideal in most
situations if you have someone who's a
champion and they champion you and they
want to be involved and they want to
help and they want to participate and
they're thinking about you and they're
they're trying to champion your cause
and so there's four buckets you have to
be in the last two in my opinion you
have to be in a positive territory with
your partner otherwise your relationship
or your business will not last long term
so what can you do now how can you move
your partner from being the negative
spot to being a more positive one I'm
gonna give you a 3-step process that I
think will help your business and your
relationship it looks like this support
communicate involve support communicate
and involve so step one is support and
what that means is you support them
support them first if you are supporting
them in their career and their ambitions
and their drive and what they're looking
for you're much more likely get support
back on you if you were just expecting
support 24/7 but you're not giving it
first it's really hard so if you want to
get it back you want to receive start by
giving and so they may not want to be
not refer that may not be how you
support them but could you support them
in their career could you support them
and their friendships could you support
them in your relationship like what are
they after
what are their goals what are their
aspirations what do they need help with
do they just need somebody to come home
and listen to them for half an hour when
they walk in the door what is it what
does support look like for them not your
version of it you know what you want
what's their version of it and
can you support them in accomplishing
their goals their ambitions their
aspirations you support them first and
then you'll get a little more support on
your rent that promise step number two
is to communicate one of the biggest
challenges with entrepreneurs is we
don't often communicate to our partners
what we're going through or thinking
about struggling with and this is
something that that Nina and I
struggling with early on in our
relationship
Nina's where's Nina Nina somewhere there
Nina's somewhere there there's the hand
so me I don't need to share what's
happening in my life I don't need to
doesn't doesn't release any stress or
attention or energy if I'm working with
something I need to just figure it out
and get to the place where I have an
answer and I'm good
Nina always wants to know what's
happening in my life she wanted to know
when she came home from work what
happened with me that day I don't even
remember what happened with me that day
I have to force myself to think about
what happened and at the beginning that
caused a little bit of tension and so I
made a dedicated effort to say okay I'm
gonna think about what's happening in my
life what's happening my business I'm
gonna make an effort to tell Nina first
before anybody else finds out she'd be
upset if she wasn't the first to know so
I make her the first to know and that
extra communication helps because she
understands my world a little bit better
even though she wasn't involved in my
world that want you to know she didn't
know much about youtube or the things
that I'm working on she couldn't be an
asset to the business yet just having
her know having her feel like she's
involved in the problems that I'm facing
at that time make everything easier so
there was an important YouTube update
that came out her or something went
wrong on the channel and she knew about
it she would say hey do you need to go
home and work on it she understands now
she's in my corner so it's not the
business being the negative the business
taking time away from us
my problem has become her problem and my
win has become her win and so it allows
her an entry point into my world and so
communicate you have to communicate you
got to set the rules you got to explain
what's going on I did an event yesterday
in Indianapolis and an entrepreneur came
up at the end and was talking to me
about how he feels the same way where
he's like super stressed out at work and
his business and he comes home and he
has no more
she left and then he comes and his wife
wants to talk immediately about what
happened to him during the day and he
just wants some time to relax and it
causes a lot of tension at home and he's
a frustrated upset that he's not
bringing his best of himself at home to
his relationships so give me some advice
one on your way home go with the
intention of how do you want the rest of
your evening to go right you're just
going home like an accident go home with
the intention if I want to have a great
night with my wife to work on
communicate and explain if you're
stressed out say who I you're stressed
out don't take it out on your partner go
home and say what happened to you and
why you're so stressed out and by you
explaining it you're bringing her into
your world she's more like than
understand and support you that's how
you can get somebody from touches
tolerating what you're doing to
supporting you because they see how
important that is to you and the
storytelling brings them into your world
and then three just the communication on
that part of maybe you need 20 minutes
to yourself when you come home maybe you
set some ground rules with your wife and
say hey I I want to tell you everything
I want to explain and be fully
transparent and let you to my world when
I come home I just need 20 minutes to
myself just to decompress just to relax
and then I'm in a much better spot
emotionally to be able to come and talk
and share what's on my mind
chances are ask you to understand that
but you just set that up you set that
communication up before so that when you
come home it's not this giant fight
every night so step two and building a
better relationship is communication and
then step number three is involving them
see what you can do to involve them into
your business into your mission into
your values if there's a fit so I'm
filming this from an Airbnb here in
Indianapolis I made a commitment to my
wife and I said I'm gonna take you to
every city in North America with a
million plus people I did that cuz she
liked to travel and I like meeting on
Twitter so how about we combine these
things together Nina loves organizing
events she loves putting on events doing
all the all the detail work all that
stuff that I'm not a huge fan of but I
didn't have a lot for her to do in my
business right she didn't want to be in
front of the camera she didn't want to
do YouTube stuff organizing events was
not a big part of what I did I do two
events a year in Toronto one in May 1 to
September teaching people how to be
thought leaders to make money from it
she definitely helped out a lot in
putting those events on and booking the
restaurants and all of that stuff she
was a huge lifesaver but it's not enough
to be heavily involved it's definitely a
full-time job so I said well what if we
found the way to integrate it what if we
combined your love of travel and your
love of organizing events my love of
helping entrepreneurs and we smush all
that together and we created this tour
we created this Frankenstein creation
where I'm visiting
in 90 days 23 different cities and that
was a cold collaboration right that was
a Coe effort on our part to combine our
missions together what we love doing and
find a way to work together what's gonna
happen you do the 90 days I don't know
there's need to go back and get another
job I don't know there's Nina find
another path to continue on in my
business I don't know we're gonna be
different people by the end of the 90
days and so we're open to be able to do
more together and so following that
three-step process thinking about how
first you can support them on what
they're doing then thinking about how
you can communicate better just to
express what you're going through and
then three trying to figure out how can
you involve them more in what you're
doing not forcing them to do something
that they don't want to do by finding an
opportunity of how they can combine
their passion with your mission as well
I think makes for a much better
work-life integration and a happier
relationship as well as a business if
you want to join the best life 30
challenge and get the free worksheets
click the link right here below me or if
you want more videos on how to have
better relationships check out the
playlist right there next to me continue
to believe and I'll see you there